family and friends are paying tribute to
Jason Spindler today he's the American
who was killed in Tuesday's terror
attack in Nairobi Kenya suicide bombers
and Gunmen from al-shabaab it's a terror
group linked to al-qaeda killed at least
21 people when they stormed a luxury
hotel complex Deborah patches in Nairobi
near the site of the attack good morning
Jason spenders parents fly into Nairobi
tomorrow to collect their son's body and
on Monday they will celebrate his life
with the diverse community of family and
friends
he is built here Jason Spindler was one
of the good guys say his parents a
former investment banker who survived
9/11 because he was late for work that
day he later gave up a high-powered Wall
Street career for the chance to make a
difference Jason once you met him you
knew this guy was gonna change the world
he had a way about him
that everyone would like him that
passion for change led him to Kenya Way
with co-founder Patricia chin Sweeney he
started a company that aims to reduce
poverty through investing and developing
economies he believed that you could
invest you could build businesses and
they would actually be a means of
stabilizing economies and and reducing
the need for for terrorism the company's
offices are housed in the complex that
was stormed by al-shabaab gunmen on
Tuesday afternoon Spindler was having a
late lunch there when a suicide bomber
blew himself up just a few meters away
it was Kenyans who bore the brunt of
this attack and at the city morgue
their unrelenting grief was rule
agonized cries for all those lives cut
short and for Spindler's family that
reality hits home on Monday which would
have been his 41st birthday security
remains tight here at the attack site
police are not letting people back into
the complex yet as they say they could
still be undetonated hand grenades that
need clearing
biana Debora patta and Kenya thank you
and of course we're thinking of Jason's
family and his parents in particular you
know to survive one tragedy only to not
make it through another they're sitting
there eating lunch p.m. giving back to
society though they have a lot of
product for him